bonjour bonjour à toutes et à tous
bienvenue ses sens public votre rendez
vous quotidien de débats de reportages
et des analyses sur public sénat avec
nos experts on donne du sens à
l'actualité on vous propose tous les
jours des clés de compréhension des
mutations de notre société 90 minutes de
débat comme tous les jours avec
l'actualité pour commencer une aide
active à mourir pourrait s'appliquer en
france à des conditions strictes c'est
l'avis rendu aujourd'hui par le comité
d'éthique première étape d'un processus
qui pourrait légaliser l'euthanasie en
france qui passera par une convention
citoyenne et peut-être un référendum
c'était une promesse du candidat macron
jusqu'où ira la loi réponse dans un
instant et puis dans la seconde partie
de l'émission c'est un débat
volontairement décalée de l'actualité du
jour que je vous propose avec cette
question faut-il boycotter la coupe du
monde au qatar vincent lindon a déjà
choisi le rap à la coupe du monde mais
c'est la même année je sais pas comme
moi je sais pas comment les
nos contemporains font pour arriver à
comprendre quelque chose à supporter
de marché de marcher la tête en bas les
pieds on est on est dans un asile géant
des milliers d'ouvriers mort en
construisant des stades climatisés pour
un événement entachée de lourds soupçons
de corruption le constat est glaçant la
polémique grandit vous verrez mais
d'abord donc cette décision du comité
national consultatif d'éthique qui
rouvre le dossier de la fin de vie
sandra ces requérants
l'avis du comité d'éthique va peut-être
marqué un tournant dans la prise en
charge de la fin de vie il appuie l'idée
d'une aide active à mourir pour des
patients dont le pronostic vital est
engagé à moyen terme
le conseil d'éthique plaide aussi pour
accélérer les efforts en faveur des
soins palliatifs et insiste sur la
nécessité de bien appliquer la loi
leonetti qui a ouvert en 2016 un droit à
la sédation profonde et continue jusqu'à
la mort pour les patients dont le décès
est proche mais le suicide assisté ou
l'euthanasie ne sont pas autorisés
nécessaire de faire évoluer la loi selon
le sénateur socialiste bernard jaume i
parce que le sujet est sérieux on ne
peut pas voter une loi approximative ça
n'est pas la même chose de légaliser
l'euthanasie de légaliser de ceux-ci
d'assister et donc il faut préciser ce
que l'on décide de faire emmanuel macron
a annoncé une convention citoyenne
organisée par le conseil économique
social et environnemental dès octobre
pendant six mois des débats seront aussi
organisées dans les territoires afin
d'aller vers tous les citoyens et le
gouvernement engagera un travail trans
partisan avec les parlementaires
la sénatrice lr marie mercier
s'interroge sur l'opportunité de
relancer un débat qui divise la société
les choses ne sont vraiment pas aussi
simple qu'on veut bien le laisser penser
on ne peut pas laisser cette réflexion
sans qu'elles soient étayés par l'avis
des professionnels ce qui n'amène à dire
qu'une consultation citoyenne je suis
extrêmement dubitatifs nous les médecins
on a déjà tellement de difficultés à se
faire une idée à essayer de comprendre
notre métier c'est le soin c'est
l'accompagnement des patients l'objectif
est d'aboutir à une nouvelle loi d'ici
fin 2023 emmanuel macron n'exclut ni un
référendum ni une issue par voie
parlementaire il s'est dit favorable à
ce que la france évolue vers le modèle
belge qui à dépénaliser l'euthanasie
sous certaines conditions depuis 2002
vous l'avez compris c'est un long
processus qui s'engage aujourd'hui pour
débattre autour de la fin de vie
j'accueille valérie depadt bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes maître de
conférences en droit privé membres la
commission 6/4 sur la fin de vie
isabelle de goldman bon soir bienvenue à
vous aussi rédactrice en chef du journal
la croix régis aubry bonsoir bienvenue à
vous membres du comité national
consultatif d'éthique rapporteur de
l'avis rendu aujourd'hui celle de
services de soins palliatifs au chu de
besançon et puis je rappelle le titre de
ce livre publié au printemps dernier
penser la fin de vie interroger la mort
pour chercher un sens à la vie c'était
aux éditions idées reçues laetitia cru
pas éditorialiste politique c'est à mes
côtés comme tous les mardis et jeudis
dans cette émission bonsoir laetitia
régis aubry peut-être tout simplement on
va faire de la pédagogie aussi dans
cette émission parce que on l'a entendu
d'ailleurs dans le sujet dans le
reportage on parle d'euthanasie on parle
de suicide assisté c'est pardon c'est
vraiment une question très basique mais
quelle est la différence
alors ce qui relie avant de dire si la
différence c2c de conception c'est le
fait que des personnes demandent une
aide
médicale à mourir
ce qui relie encore les contraintes
qu'on doit voir lorsqu'on s'intéresse à
ces deux conceptions l'assistance au
suicide et l'euthanasie
et le fait qu'il faut analyser cette
demande
ne demande ne signifie pas l'expression
ne l'ait signifie pas forcément
l'expression de là volonté de personnes
une demande peut re peut être influencé
par l' angoisse les représentations la
peur
voire par un environnement
social qui dévalorise les personnes
l'ont l'avait montré dans un avis
précédents sur les personnages et en
particulier ce qui différencie
l'euthanasie l'assistance au suicide et
l'euthanasie c'est que dans l'assistance
au suicide
après ce parcours qui fait qu'on analyse
la demande qui fait qu'on délibère pour
s'assurer que ce que demande la personne
correspond semble-t-il à sa volonté on
ouvre un droit à ce que la personne
aille se procurer un produit létal
qu'elle peut aller se procurer ou pas
qu'elle peut absorber ou pas c'est elle
qui dans l'exercice de ce qu'on appelle
l'autonomie fait susceptible de faire
cela dans le cas de l'euthanasie c'est
un tiers souvent un médecin qui
injecte un produit létal et qui engage
donc ce tiers s'engage énormément et de
notre point de vue cet engagement du
tiers est une différence fondamentale
si on est dans la réflexion qui nous
conduit se dire est ce qu'on est dans le
respect de la volonté de la personne
mais le tir n'est pas forcément un
médecin ça peut être aussi une femme les
poules
fist on peut imaginer que ce tiers soit
non professionnels de santé on n'est pas
allé sur ce registre là parce que le
fait même qu'un tiers
achète un produit létal ça enlève ce que
je disais tout à l'heure la possibilité
pour la personne de ne pas faire valérie
nos patrons voient bien la complexité de
ces questions comment une loi peut-elle
y répondre c'est ainsi le défi d'être
pays l'ont fait pions on va le faire le
mandant dans les mois prochains je crois
que ce qui rend la loi particulièrement
difficile c'est qu'à la foire brosser la
loi est un texte général abstrait qui
s'applique à tous il va falloir poser
des limites des critères de minutie pour
ne pas dépasser le champ de ce qui sera
décidé et en même temps il va falloir
permet je crois au corps médical et
patients de de respecter la singularité
de chaque situation et ça ça me paraît
particulièrement complexe parce qu'on
est dans une loi tout à fait spéciale
qui tous les plus vulnérables qui touche
les confins de la timide de la team de
l'existence c'est une loi tout à fait
particulière et à mon âge il
le chalenge état fortron isabelle de
gaulmyn c'est une loi qui pourrait
marquer une rupture est ce que vous le
craignez ben oui alors il y a deux
choses la première chose avant de parler
de rupture c'est peut-être un problème
d'opportunités dire qu'on vient de
passer une période avec le co vide on a
beaucoup parlé des ehpad de la grande
vieillesse de la grande dépendance et on
se dit qu'il ya peut-être plus urgent à
faire que d'aider les gens - rc de les
aider à bien vieillir mais pour
l'instant on n'y arrive pas et le
gouvernement a reculé à chaque fois les
la cette fameuse voix dépendance on
parlera alors à des soins de dia tiff
dans un chapitre de ce débat en français
sans fautes
après sur le sur effectivement on peut
se demander si on peut se demander si
une rupture anthropologique dans la
mesure où on est dans une société qui
est basée quand même sur la solidarité
humaine quelles que soient nos croyances
et où l'objectif par rapport à l'autre
c'est plutôt de l'aider à vivre et non
pas de l'aider à mourir donc
effectivement c'est ça qui est très
verte y nous c'est de se dire là on
franchit peut-être un tabou encore plus
si c'est le médecin qui qui qui se
charge alors en tout cas si c'est le
médecin qui se chargent usage surtout
que le problème c'est que s'est sans
doute pas la vocation des soignants la
vocation des sceaux nuances et de nous
soigner y compris ce qu'on appelle la
maladie de charcot le la sclérose
latérale amyotrophique qui est un cas
très très dur où les gens ou salées sont
petit à petit enfermés dans leur corps
on peut se dire que vraiment la première
parce que moi j'ai connu des gens très
proches de moi qu'ils ont eue là
l'objectif des médecins autour c'est de
comprendre et de se soigner et de
soulager et puis de trouver des
médicaments de trouver voilà deux de ces
c'est pas de faire mourir d'abord dont
je trouve que là en plus par rapport aux
soignants est quelque chose qui me gêne
c'est qu'on est en train de de
finalement dévoyé un peu leur le serment
d'hippocrate louis mais où est la
volonté impérieuse de l'individu dans ce
type de dilemme parce que c'est quand
même votre vie pendant qu'un médecin
décide de ma vie je ne sais pas si je
suis vraiment oui alors ça en plus en
plus le problème et c'est pas un médecin
qui décide de notre vie dans ces cas là
il y aura un dialogue fait tout les
prévu pour ça mais mais effectivement le
problème c'est qu'il ya une finalement
il ya il faut mettre en équilibre de
choses c'est le droit à l'autonomie de
ma vie c'est ma vie je peut en disposer
et puis le droit à la solidarité de
notre société nous sommes tous
responsables les uns des autres et donc
on doit s'aider les uns des autres et
cédé à vivre sur cette notion justement
de rachid eu de décision raisonnée de la
part de la nation cette possibilité
tabriz sa vie de demander abréger sa vie
doit être clair le bout d'un long chemin
parcouru par le patient et l'équipe
médicale c'est pour ça évidemment c'est
pas un acte de soin mais moi j'ai
tendance à voir ça comme le dernier acte
médical quand tout a été proposé on va
en parler vous l'avez dit y compris des
soins palliatifs d'excellente qualité
quand tout était proposé quand on ne
trouve on dispose d'aucun moyen pour
qu'une personne puisse retrouver une vie
supportable alors le médecin peut-être
plaidé régis aubry a eu d
débat interne au comité d'éthique vous
étiez peut-être pas forcément tous
d'accord sur le set sur cet avis qui si
j'ai bien compris tend plutôt vers le
suicide assisté et c'est ça oui en tout
cas compte tenu de ce que je vous disais
tout à l'heure et du sens différente
nous donnons à ces axes est évident que
si on analyse les choses au plan éthique
puisque c'est bien la fonction du comité
d'éthique c'est pathétique n'a pas à
dire ce qu'il doit faire ou pas on a été
dans l'exploration de cette tension que
vous nommez entre le devoir de respect
de la volonté des personnes et le devoir
de solidarité vis-à-vis des personnes
les plus vulnérables je ne dis pas que
ce que nous disons et ce qu'il faut dire
c'est un point de tension majeure autour
de tout cela mais il nous apparaît
important qu'on regarde cette dimension
éthique avant d'envisager à mon avis de
la question du du droit c'est
fondamental on ne peut pas imaginer
d'ailleurs au terme de cette réflexion
au considère par exemple que tout est
dit parce que j'ai déjà entendu tout est
dit dans le ccn approuve
enfin va dans le sens du droit les
cercles comme si votre avis la vie du
comité d'éthique
pratiquement alors qu'il est censé
ouvrir parce qu'un processus comme si
l'eau était en train de clore le débat
quoi parce que ce qui a été dit écrit
rudy et réécrit dans cet avis c'est
qu'il n'y aurait rien de pire que ce
qu'on pourrait appeler une l'eau sèche
c'est à dire une opinion way il ya
vraiment une question un enjeu dans
l'enjeu à mon avis c'est quel rapport
notre société peut-elle avoir dans les
décennies à venir vis-à-vis des
personnes les plus vulnérables et cette
question est d'autant plus fondamentale
que
notre société a tendance qu'on le
veuille ou non à mettre de côté les
personnes les plus vulnérables et notre
médecine qui progresse mais
corrélativement à ses progrès concours à
générer des situations de dépendance et
de vulnérabilité
il ya donc une tension très forte qui
doit interpeller le politique est
fondamentalement
ce qui fait que nous nous considérons
comme une société
c'est le fait que nous sommes capables
de solidarité jusqu'où allons-nous dans
l'exercice de cette solidarité isabelle
de balma ou louis faut absolument
souligner que cet avis il est complexe
il est très lisible mais complexe au
sens où il voit toute la complexité de
la situation et finalement c'est un avis
qu'on peut lire à peu près me
semble-t-il dans les deux sens
on peut lire la fin bon ben d'accord
avec tout tout ce qui est marqué comme
condition ou alors ben non alors là
vraiment il ya trop de choses qui sont
bouleversés donc la vie j'espère que
tous les hommes politiques qui vont
ensuite voter la loi liron bien cet avis
qui sincèrement dit toutes les bonnes
raisons pour pas le faire en quelque
sorte et mais vraiment toutes les
barrières les barrières effectivement du
point de vue des flingues point de vue
des gens du point de vue de l'entourage
parce que c'est pas facile vous avez une
mère alzheimer vous allez lui dire
écoute maman voilà je donne une pilule
parce que vraiment ça ira mieux après
est ce que ces casques et de venir te
voir souvent parce que tu es mal là
dedans parce que voilà c'est quand même
compliqué aussi pour les pour les gens
qui entourent donc je trouve que la vie
va très très bien l'ensemble de ces
problèmes et c'est vrai qu'à la fin on
s'est dit bon bah pourquoi pourquoi est
ce qu'il faudrait y aller quoi d'où
l'importance de ce qu'on appelle les
directives anticipées c'est à dire de
donner ses directives qu'on entendait
encore en état de le faire je vous ai
promis qu'on ferait de la pédagogie on
va continuer avec quentin calmer
bonsoir quentin bienvenue dans ce débat
on va tout simplement rappeler ce qui
existe quelle loi existe en france les
premières lois sur la fin de vie elle
date de la fin des années 90 exactement
le premier texte sur la fin de vie c'est
une proposition de loi grâce à laquelle
l'accès à des soins palliatifs devient
un droit en france à date de mai 1999
mais en fait c'est le choc de la sphère
vincent humbert qui va faire bouger les
lignes rappelez-vous en 2003 un jeune
homme de 22 ans tétraplégique avait
écrit à jacques chirac pour lui demander
je cite le droit de mourir je ne peux
pas vous apporter ce que vous attendez
avait répondu jacques chirac c'est sa
mère que vous voyez à l'image marie elle
qui avait pris la décision de l'aider à
mourir et d elle même par leur médecin
au risque d'être tous les deux condamnés
par la justice et ce drame avait
bouleversé les français en 2005 c'est la
première loi léonetti qui interdit en
fait l'acharnement thérapeutique cette
loi instaure en fait en creux un droit
au laisser mourir qui peut prendre la
forme d'un arrêt des soins et
l'administration de substance anti
douleur mais en fait on comprend ce sont
d'autres drames qui vont continuer à
alimenter le débat sociétal en france on
pense par exemple en 2008 à chantal
sébire qui est bien souffrant d'une
grave maladie et bien été comme cela
défiguré et donc l'évolution de la loi
suivante date de 2016 et c'est une
nouvelle loi léonetti mais avec le voilà
le deuxième député classe qui prévoit
maintenant d'instaurer une sédation
profonde et continue jusqu'au décès pour
des malades les malades atteints
d'affections graves et incurables mais
donc pas jusqu'à ce que l'on appelle
l'euthanasie active et cette loi laisse
le net il est entré complètement en
oeuvre en 2010 est donc assez récente
omari et des parlementaires tentent
régulièrement quentin de faire évoluer
le droit on voit ce débat effectivement
revenir pratiquement à chaque
législature chaque année et ça reste un
débat très clivant entre la gauche et la
droite au parlement et effectivement ce
sont plutôt les groupes de gauche qui
essaye de faire voter ses textes le
débat était vif par exemple en 2018 en
fait vrai de cette année là on avait vu
cette tribune signée par 156
parlementaires dont certains de la
république en marche il convient de
donner aux malades en fin de vie la
libre disposition de leur corps c'était
le titre de cette tribune et quinze
jours plus tard 85 parlementaires cette
fois ci c'est venu de la droite dont on
pense par exemple à philippe bas ou à
bruno retailleau il avait répondu en
disant ouvrir la porte à la légal à la
légalisation de l'euthanasie n'est ce
pas encourager cette pratique
la dernière fois que nous avons eu ce
débat dans l'hémicycle au sénat c'est en
mars 2021 c'est le groupe socialiste qui
était aligné à l'initiative la loi
n'avait donc pas été adoptée le
gouvernement d'ailleurs été contre alors
même que certains sénateurs à lèvres m
avait voté cette proposition de loi mais
à l'époque olivier ferrante avait voulu
plutôt se concentrer sur l'égal accès
aux soins pour tous à des soins
palliatifs car en 2021 et dernière
encore 26 départements disposer d'
aucune antenne pour apaiser les douleurs
des malades des malades en fin de vie
merci quand un jeu revient sur cette loi
claisse leonetti régis aubry est tout
simplement est ce qu'elle est appliquée
aujourd'hui
c'est difficile de vous répondre je
trouve que nous sommes un pays étrange
qui fabrique beaucoup de lois mais qu'il
n'y avait à lui jamais l'impact des lois
qu'il fabrique donc je ne peux pas vous
répondre précisément nous avons quand
même quelques données que le centre
national des soins palliatifs quelques
travaux de recherche je vous parlerai si
nous nous en avons le temps de la
suffisance de la recherche dans un
domaine où il faudrait qu'elle se
développe pour dire que cette loi
est insuffisamment appliquée ou plutôt
mal appliquée par et à lire par exemple
7,7 si je prends une des dispositions de
la loi de 2016 qui est le droit à la
sédation profonde et continue dans
certaines situations qui sont assez bien
définis me semble-t-il dans le cadre de
la loi lorsque le pronostic est évalué à
court terme et que la personne en fait
la demande grecque est atteint d'une
maladie rare etc on voit bien qu'il ya
une difficulté à comprendre que la
sédation n'est pas un moyen d'accélérer
la survenue de la mort n'est pas un
produit basique mais un produit qui est
destiné comme on dirait ja
altéré la confiance
en espérant que cette altération de la
conscience supprimera les souffrances
dont témoigne la partie ça vous quand on
n'est pas médecin on a effectivement du
mal à voir la différence c'est assez
compliqué et la ligne de crête est
étroite mais semble-t-il et on voit bien
que l' usage qui est fait ici et là de
la sédation ne correspond pas ni au sens
de la loi ni même aux termes qui ont été
travaillés dans le cadre de
recommandations de bonnes pratiques
professionnelles par la haute autorité
de santé donc il y a quelque chose
probablement d'une connaissance
insuffisances et d'une application
parfois inadéquat kim de droit
la différence se trouvait en tout cas
dans les travaux préparatoires dans
l'intention c'est à dire qu'avec la
sédation profonde et continue
l'intention n'était pas celle d'anne de
tuer mais de laisser la mort venir
naturellement en arrêtant l'hydratation
et l'alimentation maintenant moi je
parle sous l'autorité de régis aubry
mais les médecins avec qui je travaille
sont très méfiants prudents parce qu'ils
estiment avoir peu de recul sur cette
période ce temps de sédation profonde et
continue que vit la personne qu'est ce
qu'elle ressent et ça on le sait pas il
ya beaucoup de personnes que ça effraie
et ça effraie les familles il a eu
plusieurs vraiment une vingtaine je
crois l'année dernière de référé par des
familles qui ont trouvé trop long le
temps de la sédation pour qu'il s'était
finalement insupportable alors on dit
aussi ça aide la famille c'est moins
brutal mais ce temps vont ne sais pas ce
que vit la personne où elle peut quand
même avoir des spasmes enfin bouger une
façon ou d'une autre finalement fait
très peur isabelle de gaulmyn en vous
entendant la l'autre on se dit est parlé
de temporalité ou d'opportunités
effectivement là où on faisait référence
à la crise que vivent ces mais est-ce
qu'on a pris suffisamment le temps de
dévaluer cette loi pour déjà en mettre
une autre en chantier alors je pense que
non seulement on n'a pas pris le temps
d'évaluer mon n'a pas pris le temps de
l'expliquer aux français je suis pas sûr
que tous les français sachent que c'est
les soins palliatifs là on part tous
deux cents palliatifs on sait à peu près
ce que c'est mais donc déjà d'expliquer
que normalement quand dans un hôpital
vous avez un service ou des personnes
qui sont formés pour vous aider si
vraiment vous êtes en fin de vie à à
passer ce moment le à ne pas vous
abandonner en fait c'est ça l'idée on ne
vous abandonne pas tout seul à mourir on
vous aide à passer ce cap ensuite que
oui ça soit douloureux de toute façon la
mort elle est douloureuse la rupture
enfin c'est vrai que le temps de
sédation peut être douloureux mais c'est
de toute façon c'est douloureux de voir
un proche mourir donc ça il faut aussi
voir qu'il ya derrière cette demande
peut-être une peur de nos sociétés par
rapport à la mort une envie de la
maîtriser je pense que nous tous nous
allons mourir et ne pouvons pas
maîtriser notre notre mort en fatiha qu
il y aura toujours quelque chose qu'on
pourra pas maîtriser et y aura toujours
une douleur une mort douce et heureuse
moi je n'y crois pas alors je voudrais
justement qu'on ouvre le chapitre sur
sur ses soins palliatifs pas une
réaction était prévu un petit peu plus
tard dans l'autre débat donc je vais ça
à la rési le temps de me suivre c'est la
réaction de la réaction de claire
fourcade qui est présidente de la
société française d'accompagnement et de
soins palliatifs elle était ce matin sur
rmc elle fait un constat quand un calme
elle a amorcé ce constat elle fait un
constat sur l'état finalement 2 de
l'offre parlons de ce terme de soins
palliatifs en france la question des
gens qui vont mourir qui sont en fin de
vie c'est ce dont nous nous occupons
tous les jours je suis médecin dans un
service de soins palliatifs c'est mon
travail est actuellement pour les gens
qui vont mourir c'est pas de loi qu'on
manque c'est de moyens deux tiers des
patients qui en auraient besoin n'ont
pas accès aux soins palliatifs ces deux
cent mille personnes chaque année qui
auraient besoin d'être accompagné et qui
ne sont pas accompagnés ses 26
départements qui n'ont pas de service de
soins palliatifs et ça c'est l'urgence
et ça c'est le scandale et on a une loi
qui impose des soins palliatifs pour
tous et partout depuis 2002 il peut-être
qu'ils soient résidents de l'appliquer
il sourit c'est aussi votre métier vous
êtes je le rappelle c'est le service
soins palliatifs au chu de besançon ce
constat du manque de moyens des six il
ya évidemment un chapitre 2 de l'avis du
comité national d'éthique qui est
consacrée à ça vous dit que il faut des
moyens c'est presque un préalable à la
loi sur sur la fin de vie vous fait le
même constat je partage évidemment tous
le constat qui est fait par le docteur
pierre fourcade et
d'ailleurs c'est inquiétant parce que
on annonce des plans qui sont des
priorités de santé publique pour le
développement et on fait le constat qu
au manque de moyens j'ai moi-même
coordonner un plan il ya il y a quelques
années on fait toujours ce constat là je
pense qu'on prend pas la mesure du
besoin tout simplement
je crois personnellement que le besoin
il n'est pas tant celui des structures
de soins palliatifs que celui d'une
culture palliative intégré à la pratique
de l'ensemble des professionnels de
santé autant dire que ça renvoie mon
point de vue à la formation à
l'intégration dans la formation de la
réflexion éthique à l'intégration de
l'information de la dimension
d'incertitude la différence de la
décision médicale la plus difficile à
prendre a actuellement s'éprend de ne
pas faire ce que l'on sait faire qu'en
faire peut entraîner plus de souffrance
que de ne pas faire prendre une telle
décision est compliqué de mon point de
vue donc de mon point de vue si toujours
si je continue mon raisonnement ce qui
est important et ce qui est défaillant
c'est l'insuffisance de la formation de
la recherche je plaide depuis
15 ans je prends à peu près pour que
l'on ait des professeurs de médecine
palliative pour que l'on enseigne que
l'on fasse de la recherche à ce jour je
vous signale que nous n'avons toujours
pas de professeurs titulaires ça repart
on a fait plusieurs fois dans cette
émission des débats sur la la vieillesse
le bien vieillir sans aller forcément
jusqu'au la question des soins
palliatifs mais le tabou de la
vieillesse du mot vieux qu'on ne
prononce plus sur un plateau de de
télévision ça se rejoint une fabrique
façon le point commun entre ce que vous
dites est ce que j'évoquais c'est la
réalité de personnes en situation de
grande vulnérabilité
le paradoxe c'est que cette population
augmente à mesure que la médecine se
développent et ça on sait depuis
longtemps
dissiper les démographes nous nous nous
nous alertent depuis très longtemps et
que au plan universitaire la gériatrie
est une discipline qui n'attirent pas
les jeunes médecins parce que les
complexes parce que c'est très compliqué
et les soins palliatifs
de la même manière dont il ya quelque
chose d'un défaut fondamental s'il
fallait que nous construisions des
unités de soins palliatifs autant qu'il
y aurait des besoins d'accompagnement de
personnes je crois que nous y passerions
l'ensemble du budget de l'assurance
maladie donc ça allait pas cela qu'il
faut choisir mais néanmoins je trouve je
donne mon avis en répondant à votre
question que les moyens qui sont à l'eau
et développement les superlatifs ne sont
pas à la mesure des besoins c'est de mon
point de vue dramatique si je peux en
ajouter finalement propos de régis c'est
qu'en france les soins palliatifs arrive
effectivement en fin de vie quand les
soins curatifs sont terminés mais les
soins palliatifs sont des soins de
confort qui pourrait commencer s'il
était correctement développer dès
l'annoncé de la maladie dès le début
parce qu'on a besoin dès le début de
soins de confort entre deux périodes de
traitement lourd on peut avoir besoin
mais en france on construit on ne
conçoit les soins palliatifs que comme
la fin ce qui explique aussi peut-être
le peu d'engouement déjà nommé de fonds
d'innovation culture est équipé que deux
personnes pour lesquelles le pronostic
vital est engagé à court terme il ya
aussi une question culturelle parce
qu'il vous c'est normal vous êtes vous
êtes médecin donc vous prêchez pour
votre paroisse mais il ya aussi le
domicile c'est à dire que dans d'autres
pays ça existe les soins palliatifs à
domicile les proches lui demande où il
très difficile d'avoir des relais
justement pour avoir de l'information de
l'est les proches le demandent donc il
ya aussi cette demande qui n'est pas
forcément fourni et qui pourrait
peut-être répondre à un certain problème
de déséquilibre c'est la raison pour
laquelle parce que je trouve que je n'ai
pas de paroisses je ne prêche pas pour
les soins palliatifs hospitalier je
pense que vous avez tout à fait raison
je pense que j'avais tout à fait raison
la question du lieu de la fin de la vie
et peut-être beaucoup plus importante
que la lieue lente que la question du
lieu où l'on meurt il faudrait peut-être
que nous nous intéressions aussi à
d'autres acteurs que les acteurs
médicaux à proprement parler quand je
pense par exemple à à des acteurs
fondamentaux de l'aide au maintien à
domicile mais ça vaut pour les personnes
âgées comme pour les personnes en fin de
vie je pense aux aides à domicile je
pense vous serez aux aides soignantes
voici des professionnels - la victime en
littéralement aujourd'hui dans nos
systèmes aussi bien à domicile qu'à
l'hôpital d'ailleurs et qu'il faudrait
former il avait le goût mais on peut
saluer le site est une promesse du
candidat emmanuel macron on reviendra
sur sa communication autour de ce débat
fin de vie dans un instant laëtitia mais
on peut saluer le fait de lancer ce
débat parce que ça nous permet ça vous
permet de justement de peut-être brisé
un peu ce tabou delà de la vieillesse ce
tabou et sociétale dans ton dont on
parlait à l'instant oui ma chance c'est
que c'est quand même une occasion alors
on a déjà beaucoup débattu et c'est vrai
que peut-être qu'il faut aussi qu'on
fasse attention on a un modèle français
de l'éthique qui est assez
spécifique en europe parce qu'il a été
voilà accompagné par le ccn par les
juristes on ne fait pas n'importe quoi
dans les hôpitaux il ya qu'il ya eu
toute une évolution cette loi que l'ess
mais si elle est venue après beaucoup
beaucoup de réflexions pareil sur la
recherche sur l'embryon enfin on a en
france quand même toute une réflexion il
faudrait faire attention que le
président m'a cran qui veut semble
vouloir aller vite ne détruisent pas
cette espèce de tradition qui ne dépend
pas des religions je pense que c'est une
tradition qu'on a en france et qui est
bien de de faire attention à l'humain et
à tous nos principes et comment bien les
les imbriquer ensuite c'est vrai que moi
je trouve que la convention citoyenne
sur l'écologie avait quand même été
intéressante puisqu'elle avait permis de
voir l'écart entre un citoyen pas
informés et ensuite à la fin il était
informé alors on peut dire que que
l'euthanasie et la fin de vie c'est des
choses très très compliqué mais
l'exercice d'expliquer à des gens comme
ça à des citoyens lambda je trouve ça
intéressant et c'est bien d'en débattre
ce qu'il faudrait pas c'est que avant
que le débat soit lancé monsieur macro
et les députés lrm sache là où ils
veulent aller will et c'est
effectivement les effleurer les citoyens
les experts participé à la prise de
décisions laetitia on se penche
effectivement sur la méthode de
communication du présent la république
sur ce dossier de de la fin de vie c'est
un dossier compliqué qui est clivant
pour les politiques on l'a vu tout à
l'heure avec quentin oui il a décidé de
prendre nos méthodes en deux temps
d'abord le off et puis ensuite le honshu
explique le off c'est avec les
journalistes hier après midi où il a
expliqué comme ça pendant deux heures
avec gens naissent de l'association la
presse présidentielle ce qu'il voulait
faire et pourquoi il fait ça parce
qu'ensuite il y a bien sûr l'opinion
publique vous avez tout à fait raison il
faut informer les français mais alors
que ça s'est passé où quand comment avec
à l'elysée en fin d'après midi c'est un
c'est une une réunion annuelle qui se
fait à huit clos alors je vous conseille
l'excellent article de nos confrères
politico qui raconte les coulisses
croustillantes 1 de ce rendez vous parce
que emmanuel macron si vous voulez a
fixé le cap en fin de son second et
dernier quinquennat est alors parmi tous
les sujets
quasiment tout était off c'est à dire
que les journalistes n'avaient pas droit
de cité ensuite dans leurs articles dans
l'eure dans leurs reportages dans leurs
papiers et puis il y avait un sujet own
donc où on pouvait citer le président de
la république et c'était celui de la fin
de nuit et ce matin ce sujet étaient
dans tous les médias une question qui a
traversé y compris votre quinquennat qui
est la question de la fin de vie et de
l'autorisation de l'euthanasie cette
fois c'est lancer ses murs c'est le
moment de le faire alors nous le ferons
message adressé à line renaud c'est le 2
septembre à l'elysée quand il lui remet
la grand croix de la légion d'honneur
hier soir le président de la république
a indiqué qu'une convention citoyenne
allait se pencher sur le sujet pendant
six mois il n'exclut pas de changer la
loi il n'exclut pas un référendum alors
vous voyez en fonction des médias on
assume ou pas la réunion d'hier parfois
on met ça c'est vrai que quand il a
décoré les noms de ils avaient dit
qu'ils allaient bouger ça c'est vrai
mais avant même que le comité d'éthique
finalement ne rende son avis à 9 heures
les français étaient quasiment tous il
écoutait la radio avait lu la presse au
courant de ce qui allait se passer et
l'elysée a tout de même attendu votre
hockey pour envoyer un
communiqué à la presse avec la méthode
alors ça c'est le deuxième étage à la
fusée on va dire la communication à
destination des français mais oui avec
la convention citoyenne sur la fin de
vie organisé par le 6 le conseil
économique social et environnemental que
les oppositions avaient rappelé au bon
souvenir du président emmanuel macron
démontre qu'il veut placer son second
quinquennat sous le signe de la
concertation avec les parlementaires
parce que il négociera avec les députés
et les sénateurs mais aussi la
participation citoyenne et l'a
certainement retenu sans le citer les
leçons de son ancien et de notre ancien
président françois hollande qui lui même
en 2013 avait lancé une convention
citoyenne sur la fin de vie avant de
faire adopter la loi claisse leonetti en
2016 emmanuel macron se distinguera
peut-être s'il choisit le référendum
pour enfin a débouché sur cette course
alors justement je voudrais bien besoin
donc tous les trois sur cette question
de référendum je commence avec valérie
de pâte est ce que c'est le bon objet
juridique
plus la démocratie et démocratique mieux
c'est simplement c'est un sujet je crois
qu'on sera tous les trois d'accord pour
dire sur les cas sur lequel on travaille
depuis longtemps
et il est très compliqué à mon avis il
faut un cheminement il faut du temps
pour bien comprendre les enjeux c'est
pas oui non je suis pour je suis content
oui mais un référendum par définition
c'est une question à laquelle on répond
par oui non donc ça s'est vu voilà les
sujets naître la crainte c'est que les
français ne soient pas suffisamment
informés avant de cécité munich et de
l'elysée et des biens précisé qu'en
parallèle de la convention week-end il y
aura dans tous les territoires des
discussions des voix là pour informer
les c'est pour ça moi le seul bémol que
j'aime et c'est la formation et le sens
des enjeux et des conséquences isabelle
de gaulmyn ferait faire un dogme mais il
est favorable des femmes connaissent moi
je trouve effectivement que c'est une
question tellement compliqué tout le
monde veut bien mourir si on me demande
ce que voulait bien mourir ou mourir
dans la dignité je dirais oui oui mais
c'est à dire les sondages
parce qu'en fait ils comprennent pas la
question donc pour moi il ya un rôle du
politique il ya eu un honneur du
politique et qui est encore une fois sur
l'éthique qui a quand même une tradition
jeu vers la dernière loi les la gauche
la droite sont retrouvés dessus donc
c'est possible donc on moi je trouve que
c'est vraiment aux politiques à la fin
d' après tout cette concertation de
devoir de choisir est ce que ce que
j'espère c'est que ça va pas être
l'occasion pourrait mener le maquereau
et isabelle borne de juste faire un
petit coup de façon à prendre les voix
de la gauche parce qu'en fait c'est
quand même ça qu'il ya derrière il ya
une toute une gauche qui est pour et
d'ailleurs c'est drôle que la gauche
soit pour parce que c'est quand même une
fois hyper libérale c'est dire moi je
j'ai le droit d'être autonomes donc
aujourd'hui la gauche elle est
complètement libéral quoi la solidarité
avec les plus vulnérables avec les plus
vieux avec les plus pauvres c'est pas
dans son champ de regard tout cas quand
on écoute ce matin les réactions
politiques la gauche était pour le
référendum notamment la france est
soumise et puis à l'extrême droite
marine le pen non était coupable marine
le pen était pour le référendum et la
gauche voulait la voie parlementaire
vous voyez déjà sur la méthode y avait
quand même une opposition votre avenir
et laisse aux prix
j'ai tendance à penser qu'il ne faut pas
confondre la fin et les moyens ce dont
on parle là le débat public le
référendum ce sont des moyens ceux dont
on devrait parler me semble-t-il c'est
la faim et la faim elle vaut la peine
qu'on y réfléchisse et l'exercice de la
démocratie
comment on débat de questions complexes
qui nous concerne tous
qui réveille chez nous des
représentations des peurs des angoisses
ou qui mobilise des idées reçues comment
on arrive à débattre sur un objet
complexe comme celui-ci ce que je vous
rappelle quand même que la complexité de
la fin de vie et de la mort c'est que
personne dans les revenus pour en
témoigner et donc c'est un peu compliqué
de parler de ce qu'on ne connaît pas et
donc la difficulté pour moi et l'enjeu
dans l'enjeu de la question de la fin de
vie c'est l'exercice de démocratie et je
pense qu'il ya là quelque chose
d'extrêmement important est peut-être
dangereux alors dans ce débat il ya une
joie qu'on entend beaucoup depuis
plusieurs mois les terrains de donner
encore une interview ce matin dans le
journal le parisien aujourd'hui en
france et la voix de line renaud marqué
par son histoire personnelle écoutez la
c'était en novembre 2000 21 sur le
plateau de c'est à vous il faut partir
avant il sourit mais la complexité vous
l'avez expliqué pour les médecins c'est
d'évaluer cet avant
oui mais je pense qu'on a tous un avis
sur la question la preuve line renaud et
au nom de quoi la vie de l'un d'entre
nous contre plus que la vie d'un autre
est il important
précisément c'est là que se situe
l'enjeu démocratique principal c'est
comment on fait on partage des
expériences personnelles
ou arriver à se décentrer par rapport à
son expérience et regarder l'objet
complexe qu'à celui de la fin de vie
pour en débattre sans affect ou sans
trop d'affect donc une convention
citoyenne c'est un bon outil d'une
certaine façon pour voudront une
convention citoyenne et un débat on ont
contribué à ce que les espaces de
réflexion éthique qui existent dans
chaque région et dont une des missions
est allé à la rencontre des citoyens
pour aborder ces questions complexes que
l'eau que sont les questions éthiques en
l'occurrence les questions de fin de vie
ces deux moyens de débattre mais les
peuvent aboutir à quelque chose
d'intéressant j'espère qu'on évitera le
référendum parce que je n'ai pas répondu
à votre question je pense que ce serait
un mauvais outil pour le coup un mauvais
moyen pour explorer une réalité aussi
complets que ceux ci alors
convention citoyenne et référendum on
pourrait dire on est ici à public sénat
que c'est un moyen de de passer outre le
travail des parlementaires alors on peut
on peut soit le regretté soit dire
puisque vous dis attention aux arrières
pensées politiques c'est peut-être aussi
un moyen de d'éviter ses arrières pour
ses politiques ou de les limiter les
réduire vous en pensez
l'extrême gauche a pas apparemment et
contre un référendum je ne sais pas s'il
est aussi à une volonté d'aller vite
parce qu'il ya aussi derrière des macros
risque est d'ailleurs assez étrange
c'est pourquoi pour moi vouloir aller
vite est-ce que ce que je voudrais vous
dire ce que disait line renaud c'est
vrai ce qui est anormal c'est la
souffrance on doit pas souffrir si
vraiment les gentils dans une souffrance
atroce avant de mourir il ya quelque
chose qui s'est mal passé après il ya
aussi une souffrance de partir est une
souffrance aussi de l'entourage donc il
faudrait qu'elle analyse mieux cette
souffrance qu'on sache de quoi on parle
est ce que c'est la souffrance parce que
sa mère est en train de partir est ce
que c'est la souffrance de la mer et là
c'est pas normal et là ça renvoie au
problème des sans papiers c'est ce que
j'avais à vous dire les
départements simplement les moyens alors
on peut imaginer il faut pas souffrir
elle parle d'eux
deux des ses anciens line renaud mais on
peut imaginer que il ya eu des soins
palliatifs en tout cas des moyens au dos
au tour et moi je me pose quand même une
question quelle sera la question posée
aux français mais oui c'est pour ça
qu'on va faire c'est très complète la
loi sera pas faite une fois le résultat
du référendum publiés qu'est ce qu'on va
leur demander effectivement si c est ce
que vous voulez bien mourir dans de
bonnes conditions
oui on peut proposer un texte la voix la
cohésion oui ou non un oui d'accord mais
qu'il aussi le viral sexe complexe pour
le coup voilà moi je me demande jusqu'à
sera la question posée on a regardé un
peu les législations ailleurs en europe
les pays d'europe qui autorise
l'euthanasie
les pays bas la belgique le luxembourg
l'espagne et les pays d'europe qui
autorise le suicide assisté luxembourg
espagne suisse autriche je rappelle la
différence l'euthanasie c'est un tiers
qui peut être un médecin qui administre
le produit létal le suicide assisté on
on permet à la personne d'aller chercher
elle-même le produit si j'ai bien résumé
ce que vous nous expliquer tout à
l'heure je parlais de la suisse la
suisse où vivaient jean luc godard le
cinéaste d'autres temps on a appris la
mort aujourd'hui il a choisi le suicide
assisté c'est ce que un proche de la
famille a annoncé au quotidien
libération regarder je cite ce
témoignage il n'était pas malade il
était simplement épuisé il avait donc
pris la décision d'en finir c'était sa
décision c'était important pour lui que
ça se sache et ça me rappelle un autre
acte d'une certaine façon militants
c'est celui de la maman de la mer de
lionel jospin morte en 2002 à l'âge de
92 ans et voici ce que disait son avis
de décès mireille jospin dans dieu sage
femme veuve de robert jospin membre du
comité de parrainage de l'association
pour le droit à mourir dans la dignité a
décidé dans la sérénité de quitter la
vie à l'âge de 92 ans le 6 décembre 2002
régis aubry alors je suis pas dans le
l'intimité de ces deux familles mais ce
que je comprends c'est que jean luc
godard et mére j'ose pas n'était pas
malade
ils ont fait le choix de partir la loi
française leur interdisait donc ils se
sont enfin pour mirallas est mise hors
la loi c'est aussi pour
trouver une solution face à ces familles
qui veulent aller jusque là qu'il faut
faire évoluer notre loi d'après vous on
n'est pas allé aussi loin dans notre
réflexion
et on n'y est pas allé volontairement
c'est à dire que demander de l'aide
parce qu'on est fatigué de vivre si je
résume oui un peu ce que vous expliquez
je porte pas de jugement sur non plus
sur cela parce que qu'ils seraient jeu
pour emporter mais c'est quand même
différent que de demander de l'aide à
mourir lorsqu'on souffre tant que la vie
n'a plus de sens pour nous et sur ce
deuxième point nous avons fait porter
notre réflexion et c'est à mon avis
quand même par là que nous devons
commencer la réflexion me semble-t-il il
y aurait quelque chose de totalement
incongrue à ouvrir la possibilité de
l'assistance au suicide en dehors du
champ de la pathologie vous me dites ce
sont des débats différents poids parce
que c'est adema différent que de savoir
si on peut répondre à la demande d'une
personne pour qui la vie n'est plus que
souffrance est devenu insupportable et
répondre à une demande qui serait
simplement de choisir le moment de son
décès c'est ça ce sont deux choses quand
même différente et ses pardons et ne
serait-ce que plus autonome un peu moins
vulnérable que celle qui est dans une
souffrance extrême la fille de denis
rebmann avait raconté sa dans un livre
je crois c'était la dernière leçon le
titre de ce livre moi j'avais été frappé
par la sérénité familial c'est à dire
que ce choix de leur maman on leur a
donné la possibilité pendant un an que
la date avait été annoncée de discuter
de se souvenir des bons moments enfin ça
ne m'avait pas choquer finalement
raconté de cette façon là en fait moi je
crois que tout le monde peut se suicider
société c'est quand même un drame le
suicidaire mais tout ceci dit vous
pouvez pas empêcher quelqu'un de se
suicider donc voilà si si on veut en
finir et on peut on peut se suicider
après je pense que le grand le grand
danger que qu'ils se porteraient bien
l'avis du comité national d'éthique
c'est que si vous donnez une possibilité
en disant bas chez mamie tu peux
demander alors
quand on est malade je n'ose pas on a
les moyens d'organiser ce truc c'était
un acteur pour s'appuie donc quand on
est quelqu'un en dépendance avec pas
beaucoup de moyens kiki qui est pas
forcément toute sa tête etc on peut
sentir ça comme une pression et qu'est
ce qui nous dit qu'ensuite tu auras pas
des pressions pour effectivement les
gens vont se sentir même eux mêmes en
fait je veux pas peser sur mes enfants
mais c'est horrible si on en arrive là
c'est pour pas pesé sur ses enfants on
va se faire mourir je trouve qu'on est
dans une société qui marche sur la tête
et sourit oui moi je serais je serais
inquiet on peut comprendre
individuellement une telle démarche mais
là on parle bien d'un louis direction
avec ce qui ce serait risqué parce que
en même temps que nous discutons de cela
j'ai en mémoire des travaux que nous
avons pu conduire par ailleurs et en
particulier sur les enjeux éthiques du
vieillissement et où nous montrions où
nous avions découvert avec un certain
effroi la réalité du suicide en france
des personnes âgées et en particulier
dans les explications possibles de ce
taux très élevé du suicide des personnes
âgées en france par rapport aux autres
pays d'europe une des explications était
le sentiment d'indignité que pouf que
peuvent éprouver des personnes âgées
lorsqu'elles ont le sentiment d'être un
poids pour autrui d'être une charge et
de ne plus être utile je crois qu'il y
aurait un danger à considérer que ces
personnes étant fatigués de vivre il
fallait donc qu'elles cessent de vivre
il ya peut-être une autre considération
avoir vis-à-vis des personnages et c'est
considérer qu'elles ont une certaine
sagesse qu'il nous faudrait pouvoir
utiliser mais ça appelle on revient au
début de notre débat ça appelle une
véritable politique d'accompagnement du
vieillissement qui aillent dans ces
interstices qu'est-ce que vieillir ou
qu'est ce qu'être vieux signifie dans
une société comme la nôtre qui est une
société qui valorise quand même plutôt
la jeunesse la performance voire la
rentabilité qui aide à vivre aussi pur
beaucoup plus longtemps
à vivre plus longtemps voyez cette
espèce de paradoxe qu'il ya qu'il faut
interroger dans notre société de mon
point de vue c'est ce niveau de tension
éthique doit faire l'objet des débats
publics c'est important parce que je
suis persuadé que tout le monde peut
entrer dans cette dimension du débat
merci beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat le régisseur et
j'appelle le le titre de votre livre
penser la fin de vie interroger la mort
pour chercher un sens à la vie publié
aux éditions idées reçues